Speaker 1: A 15 year old shot, three
of his four siblings and then himself
and everybody is dead. And this is
one of those cases I've said before,
you got to charge the people that are supposed
to be in charge of the gun. This is a tragedy,
but you've got to charge the people that
are supposed to be in charge of the gun.
Alaska News source reports four children dead in
Fairbanks after 15 year old shot, three siblings
and himself per troopers. Four children are dead.
God, what a tragedy. After a 15 year old turned a
gun on three of his siblings and then took his
own life, that's per Alaska state troopers.
This happened on Tuesday. Troopers got a report
of a shooting at a subdivision north of Fairbanks,
Alaska. The troopers showed up and found four kids
dead from an apparent gunshot wound. Troopers said
that a 15 year old boy shot three siblings.
The siblings were aged five, eight and 17
and then shot himself or its three other siblings
in the home were not injured, not one other three
other siblings in the home. So the parents of the
children and one other sibling were also not home.
So one sibling, three others is four. And then the
three that were shot is seven and then eight. So
you've got a house. It's an it's a very,
very small house. There's images of the house
in some of the news articles. You've got eight
siblings and you've got an unsecured gun. Now,
there has not been a lot of detail here, but one
of the questions is whose gun was it and how did
the 15 year old get access to it? Well, according
to NBC News, the gun was a family gun. By the way,
the term family gun, that is uniquely American. It
was a family gun. But beyond that, it's all still
part of an ongoing investigation. If
indeed. I mean, listen, family gun,
the 15 year old's not allowed to have the gun.
So by family gun, it probably means that this was
a firearm. That belonged to and it was purchased
by the parent or parents. And if that's the case,
the firearm being accessible to the 15 year
old would be a negligent act by the parents,
by the gun owners. And we often talk about when
there are these so-called accidental shootings,
which are really negligent shootings, where the
gun owner accidentally fires a gun at someone,
we say, well, that's really a tragedy.
And do we want to add more to what is
already a tragedy when a dad accidentally
shoots his own kid as we've covered before
and the kid dies? That's the tragedy. So do we
really want to go after the parent for a negligent
gun discharge, given that they've lost their kid?
Well, I don't know. It's not really my decision to
make. But further here we have a situation where,
of course, this is a tragedy for the parents.
But what is the signal being sent
if the parents didn't properly store
and lock the firearm? And then it was accessible
to a 15 year old who then killed three of his
siblings and himself. What's the message
that sent if the parents aren't charged?
I don't know. I'd like to hear from you
about that. One other aspect in general,
and when you have an individual incident
here, this is an individual mass shooting,
individual mass shootings and broader statistics.
Sometimes they correlate, sometimes they don't,
or whatever the case may be. Alaska has the number
one gun homicide rate in the country. The gun
homicide rate in Alaska is over 24 gun homicides
per 100,000 people. Now, if you're wondering
whether 24 is high. New York and Massachusetts,
the two states with the lowest gun homicide rate
have a gun homicide rate of three. Okay. That's
we're talking about seven times higher, more than
seven times higher. The gun homicide rate is three
in New York and Massachusetts and it's more than
24 in Alaska. It just so happens that gun laws
in Alaska are not strict and gun laws in New York
and Massachusetts are strict. And once again, we
see that correlation. This one story is just an
anecdote, but I think it's always important to
kind of pull out and to say, well, what's the
context in Alaska and what's the context in some
of these other states? For all of the you know,
there's the woke bashing that takes place. Oh, New
York is so dangerous. And it's just riddled with
urban gun crime euphemisms. Right. The gun
homicide rate in Alaska is extraordinarily high.
And Anchorage, Alaska is consistently for among
in the United States a very dangerous metro area
when it comes to violent crime. Barely ever
makes the news. I don't know if it doesn't
fit with the narrative of the right. I
don't know if it's because Alaska is so
geographically distant from the contiguous 48
states. I don't pretend to know exactly why,
but that is the truth. Those are the numbers. And
just another horrible, horrible tragedy. And if
only we could do something about this right away.
This is a problem that plagues the United States
and almost no other wealthy Western nation.
Yeah. Make sure you follow us on Facebook for
more on this and other stories from today's
show, Facebook.com Slash David Pakman show.